hey
we're live look tom's back again today
yeah i'm back we're here yesterday it
was like a big blank space
i had to go get a bunch of [ __ ] had to
go get supplies
had to go get rice and beans yeah rice
beans and
um sugar and um powdered milk
powder milk man they had that damn
goya tre choizo on sale
and the chorizo is like [ __ ] and i was
looking at the [ __ ] nutrition and the
calories and everything for like two
dollars and fifty cents
you get all that damn protein and it was
like packaged like a damn mre and i was
like man you could go to the field with
this [ __ ]
so i i asked i asked my boy khan of
atlanta
over in tijuana i said man what do i do
with this chorizo you know besides
beans and rice and [ __ ] he goes man that
makes good tacos
yeah then he started getting on me
you're saying man that's a spanish
company that's not a mexican company we
don't [ __ ] with the spanish he's like
you know that's this guy's bad
no don't do that you know it's puerto
ricans that eat that
not mexicans so you know yeah
they don't eat they don't [ __ ] with goya
they don't have it in mexico i thought
it's right here oh my hair was getting
here made me look more handsome
i make you look more handsome yeah well
he's just he just came in a second ago
and he's like my hair is [ __ ] up so
i'm gonna wear a hat and then i was like
that i looked over and i realized he
didn't have another that's right i got
that [ __ ] [ __ ] ranger roll
that's my od green [ __ ] patrol cap
i'm going on patrol right now
he's playing internet patrol
got mango badger in here sandra's in
here
i know okay all our regular people are
in here they're talking about
who's this guy
[Laughter]
man see one day you're missing and like
everyone just forgets
all about you yeah i was like i said i
said this yesterday but
the movie retrospective that goes up on
friday is just me too
yeah because dad just called me honorary
italian yeah
oh yeah i should have been bored italian
yeah you think yeah maybe
all right maybe do you want to do some
shout outs
go ahead okay so we have a couple of
shout outs today
uh first of all i want to thank louie
for sending us
uh two movies he sent us the big
lebowski and he sent us
collateral with tom cruise so that is
very exciting
i don't have it with me because i
already put them back in the bedroom
because we're going to watch them later
and also sophie sent us this today we
just got a couple minutes ago
yeah this is a horror comedy called the
voices
yeah with ryan reynolds i actually saw
this a couple years back and it is
hilarious yeah she was telling me about
it she said yeah i think you'll like it
i think
that's like it is really very funny i
thought it was very sophie's trying to
come down here for a visit
and uh she'll probably be a guest on the
show yeah she should be down
she'll be down for at least a week that
i would think yeah last time she was
here it was about a week
i think so yeah yeah wait a minute yeah
she says she's
she says she's sick of it she wants to
come hang out
[Laughter]
yeah you come down here to florida even
though it's kind of locked down in
florida still
yeah mannequins is open we can't really
go anywhere i mean i think you can only
go there if you sit outside
maybe i don't know we'll see
i kind of got some feedback that it was
kind of just like regular but
yeah tell anybody yeah get in trouble
it'd probably be a it'll probably be
over by then anyway hopefully
but uh yeah another thing i wanted to
shout out to you i think on the regular
show that we did on saturday night
um i was showing people my uh new card
decks
uh that i had i have four like different
card decks i got art nouveau ones i got
edgar allan poe ones i got ancient egypt
ones i got ancient greece ones
and those are all up for sale on my
store on the game crafter like i said i
have a whole bunch of other games too
but i haven't like
ordered proof copies yet also my
short story collection hopeful monsters
that i did
a new second edition of all
the formats are now available meaning
print and ebook
and the audiobook oh just what today
no [ __ ] yeah that seemed to take fred
took forever
it did yeah it is taking like longer i
don't know i think they have like a big
backlog maybe
yeah but yeah so the next one i'm gonna
do because i'm gonna do a second edition
of some of my novels as well
um so i have like a print and an e-book
done for my net for
one of my old novels and then i just
have to do an audio version do you have
any codes for
open monsters i do yeah they're in my
email okay i tell you what if you guys
want uh
a free copy of um hopeful monsters on
audiobook
hit give jenny a send her a private
message
yeah either my email or facebook or
something like that and i think they
send me 25
codes and we'll send you a free code
free download code for that book for the
audiobook
and short stories yeah in exchange for a
review
yeah okay you gotta leave a review yeah
and
let her do it all right so that's a
special offer to you to y'all today
yeah that's right yeah it just went the
audio just went up today yeah we shot
the second batch of shirts
so everybody's shirts are shot yeah
going out i have fun
that's just five people that um that i
needed to they got backed up because i
didn't have enough
sizes and blah blah blah and they're
going to be going out there either today
or tomorrow yeah we're either going to
go
and i must say that the snake pliskin
shirts
were actually better today than the
first batch and it's because i
i guess i gotta got the hang on how much
paint should go through and how hard to
press on it yeah
they look pretty cool they're better
than mine yeah i might reshoot that [ __ ]
so i have some [ __ ] bad ass ones
i got the screen but you know yeah they
came out really good
yeah yeah they are they're very
beautiful yeah and then like uh
the regular shirts maybe it takes time
to break the screens in
i'm not really sure that it is i'm not
i'm not a professional they just came
out just
real [ __ ] crisp and the paint was
just the right thickness on them they
just look they looked really good
yeah you did a good job i'm calling it
paint it's not really paints dye
but whatever you want
so uh let's kind of talk about this
movie for a second since that's kind of
what the
topic is so this is another one
where we were just looking for a new
movie just so we would have like a movie
to offensively talk about
do they send the games to europe that's
what they're asking uh
i i imagine that they do yeah yeah um
it's i as far as i know it's an
international uh site
but i can check for you if you want
probably i would think so yeah i would
think
so too because i mean i've seen there's
like 40 bajillion games on there and i'm
sure that like some of the people are
from overseas um so we're scrolling
through
like i didn't really want to okay
there's like i have a list of horror
movies
that you know like i look on rotten
tomatoes like the ones that are like
highest rated and whatever
and i made a list of like ones i wanted
to do but the one the main one that i
wanted to do i wanted to rent it on xbox
but it wasn't available
like i think you can run it on youtube
but they didn't have it to run on xbox
and we can rent the [ __ ] on youtube but
it's kind of a pain in the ass because
he has to cast it from his [ __ ]
tablet and it's like a nightmare so i
was just like all right [ __ ] it well i'm
just going to look on 2b
and get another new one off of there
soon i have a [ __ ] ton
of like 20 20 horror movies to pick from
so we were just kind of scrolling
through it's like for a second we were
thinking about
vikings versus krampus which i was kind
of like
that kind of says it tricky people will
watch that tonight i don't know
but then we were like scrolling through
and then we saw this one
and the you know the poster was kind of
cool
and the you know just the little
uh description of it sounded kind of
neat so i was like all right let's watch
this one it's called distiller
now the weird thing about it is that on
2b it's listed as a 2020 movie but then
when i looked it up later i think it was
actually made or released
originally in 2016 so it's actually four
years old
yeah this movie whatever whatever this
movie here
was uh for me a mixed bag this is it i
mean i'm telling you right now this is a
micro budget yeah micro budget
maybe a little bit more of a budget than
say like ouija shark
but probably not all that much it was a
mixed bag
with this one it had
the main problem with it is that it was
the edit it was a little bit too long
yeah they they left some stuff in there
it's kind of like they padded certain
things out for a few minutes they left
some stuff in there
that didn't have to be in there and i
think that was
because they were trying to get like a
feature length
uh it looked like it was made over us
over kind of a
a few years time because
it kind of got better as it went the
special effects towards the end
almost looked like real top-notch
special effects from the 80s
yeah i mean they're cheese ball but like
in a fun way in a fun way
um kind of reminded me it had good
practical effects in terms of little
puppets and [ __ ]
um it had some of that [ __ ] kind of
throwback zaniness that you saw in in
horror movies
it had some cg enhancements which i
liked
uh overall the end part of it was a lot
more fun than some of the slow stuff
that was like
used as filler yeah it kind of sagged a
bit in the middle it sagged a little bit
in the middle
like i think i would have had a lot
better experience you cut about 20
minutes of the movie out
yeah and i mean it's only like an hour
and a half it was like an hour and 28
minutes
the beginning of it actually looks
lower budget than the end but that
wasn't bad
i kind of liked it it was
it kind of gave me that manos type
feeling mano's hands of faith
hands hands
[Laughter]
where you know what i mean it didn't
have a it didn't have a
live voice track they they they they
overdubbed which was a little
off-putting
like i got used to it after the first 10
minutes or so
yeah but i was just kind of like i
wonder why they did that like i wonder
if
like they recorded sound like on-site
but it wasn't good enough
so then they went back and like
re-dubbed everything
like in adr so it seemed like that's
what they did
um also i think like the the sound mix
was like really strange because
this movie had a score which we were
kind of excited i was kind of excited
movie had a score it had like an actual
that sounded like a movie score but it
was
loud a little bit too loud which might
have been the reason
maybe i don't know what it was but it's
just like they had this weird thing
whereas like the score was going through
the whole thing which was kind of good
but then
the the voices were over dubbed so it
kind of sounded like
yeah i don't know it was just very very
strange yeah the sound
the sound mix with sound mixing was not
right yeah
the score was a little too loud and then
the dialogue was all dubbed and the
dialogue itself was kind of
there was too much dialogue that's
that's that's something that's something
that's
thomas says what kind of horror is it
supernatural or sci-fi it's definitely
supernatural yeah
um it's basically what the premise of
the movie is
uh what you get is you get like a
prologue i guess there's a dude i don't
i don't know anyone's names in this
movie yeah that was another thing
i don't remember anyone really sure what
anybody's names
well okay the brother's name was charlie
yeah right
i don't remember what this sister is it
was a brother and sister but then they
had an uncle
uncle [ __ ] what's that dude's uncle [ __ ]
that uncle grandpa
i don't remember i don't know what it is
i don't remember what the uncle's name
was a lot of the [ __ ] that you're asking
doesn't matter
it's i don't because i'm not
sure i'm actually not sure if this movie
was coherent
i'm not sure yeah story okay so
i don't think it did make sense yeah
i mean i got the gist yeah
like the premise of it so you start with
like a prologue and there's this guy
who's like the uncle uncle [ __ ] i can't
remember what his name is
and he's like he's like an exorcist an
exorcist or like a demon
person yeah or something like who who
like rids people of or rids people's
houses of demons or spirits or whatever
i was
under the impression it was something
kind of yiddish
or maybe something kind of like jewish
mysticism maybe but i didn't really i
don't know i didn't really get that it
seems like a lot more
generic than that i guess it was hard to
tell
but you know there was a lot of you know
a lot of the accents were like
you know you can't you they were yeah
but that's because it was set in upstate
upstate new york and i was under the
impression that it might have had some
kind of jewish lord
to some of it maybe but like i said
really the only
like lore they went into like in depth i
guess
um it was about the grim yeah like the
dog was the cemetery
and [ __ ] like that which is scandinavian
right so the thing about it is that
so this guy who's like an exorcist or
whatever and
something that he does when he goes to
rid someone's house of a spirit or demon
or evil spirit or whatever the hell it
is
he traps them in liquor bottles so it's
almost like a genie type of thing too
yeah so he traps them in liquor bottles
and then like he tells the people
you know nobody wants like the liquor
bottles to be left at their house so
apparently he's got like a big
collection of them now
and it's like if you drink the liquor or
you're [ __ ] if you break the bottle
you're [ __ ] because you're like
letting the demon back out i guess
so it is funny drinking milk makes it
strong make some
oh yeah that's you i forgot about that
so he's some kind of exorcist all right
i wasn't really sure the stuff that he
was doing i was under the impression it
to me it looked
it looked like something kind of yiddish
you know i mean where the rituals would
make the dream that that was just my
impression
maybe it's yeah i'm not right have been
something totally invasive because it
seemed
well it seems just very generic it
seemed like there
here's a plate with a candle on it and
they poured bourbon in there and then
they made a thing with salt let's just
see
it's very generic i was just getting
this dybic box vibe
from it maybe that's just because of the
weird we're trapping a demon inside
something
right which i think which a lot of
cultures have that i think yeah
so maybe that's just i was thinking it
was like debit box but so
the weird thing about this though and
the reason that you're saying that it's
like kind of
was like incoherent in spots because it
seemed like it was like funny because he
was like you know kind of smart assy
like at first yeah
with the thing i tried to be a lot of
humor in it it was kind of funny it was
kind of funny
there was a couple jokes that i liked
what happens is that when there's
there was too much dialogue that was not
really centered on the story itself so
it starts sending you down these side
tracks
like you know like on our show like on
our show get sidetracked
but not but not as fun as our show you
lose track of what
what's important and what isn't so you
end up with kind of like muddy dialogue
especially when he goes to [ __ ]
up in nepal paul which i think was
actually the sierra nevada mountain yes
and then runs it goes into paul finds a
buddhist statue and gets attacked by the
yeti
that right that's what happened right
yeah hell [ __ ] right that's what
happened that was the [ __ ]
abominable or the abdominal snowman one
of the two
and i didn't really doubt by the way i
didn't know like what that had to do
with the rest of them
yeah so i thought it was gonna go
somewhere with this but
you never see the yeti again the yeti's
never [ __ ] explained it's never
mentioned
that's because he got so random and he
didn't get killed by the yeti because
you see him again later if i remember
correctly
okay now see that's what i thought i
thought that
the yeti or or bigfoot or whatever the
[ __ ] that was i thought it killed him
and then that's why because after that
scene yeah that's when his
niece and nephew like his brother and
sister that's when they learn that
they've inherited his house
and they're going to clean his house out
like she inherited or whatever
so they go there to clean it out and
that's kind of what the bulk of the
movie is the two of them
cleaning out the house but then you find
out later on that he's still alive
yeah and it hasn't aged even though that
happened he put a little bit of gray in
his head that was back in the 80s and
all of a sudden he's now in 2007
it was 2014. that was when it was set
all right
but like yeah so i didn't really get why
like i i think the i think what they
were trying to get to
was that they were showing because they
showed him
in different places like they showed him
in tibet which i don't think
i hope i don't know if that was actually
tibet let's fly to tibet to film like a
two-minute scene
like for this like you know no that was
a dollar ninety-eight movie right that
was that was and then there was like him
he was in oregon and yeah so i think
they were showing him like being a globe
trotting
exorcist who was going around the world
like picking up these demons from like
like different types of demons or
different types of evil spirits from
different locations
yeah and putting them and keeping them
in these bottles so that when they all
get uh released spoiler alert i mean
obviously that's what's going to happen
in the movie
is when they all get released you'll be
like oh this is all of the evil spirits
from like all around the world and oh
[ __ ] they're all getting released all at
once i think
yeah now that now that i think that that
first
part of the movie
wasn't bad i i i actually was amused
but then it goes to his kids or his his
niece and nephew
that's what it is and they're kind of
living together as brother and sister
but
in a weird way that they're they seem
like they're a little bit too much too
friendly like they're
and they inherit his house well she and
harrison
he's just there to help her like clean
all the [ __ ] out and then he's gonna
leave and they spent a lot of time
together talking and [ __ ] around and
making
and and saying things that are not of
any really consequences this is where
the movie starts to sag and then they
have a fourth of july party or they're
planning a fourth of july party like
with all their friends
right because it's set up for fourth
generation starts to pick back up around
that
around that time because they just show
a bunch of like gratuitous bikini shots
over
yeah man and other girls at the time and
other girls
actually give that a thumbs up okay
everybody has all of these movies have
to have girls
it's free yeah it doesn't cost anything
to tell them to put bikinis on so
thank you thank you very much
well the movie starts to pick up starts
to become more like a monster movie when
they accidentally release all the
[ __ ] demons
yeah from the booze because of course
they find all this booze
in the basement and they're like well
the first thing we should do obviously
is drink all that [ __ ] yeah
and uh and it starts going into a bunch
of kind of like
horror horror sci-fi adventure kind of
seeds
which were actually pretty good i
thought i think i think the special
effects looked
it was a lot better than i was expecting
yes like these
special effects looked pretty good they
would have been passable in in the 80s
in the 80s
yeah yeah and which kind of gave it kind
of a
kind of a throwback charm to it i liked
it
um it wasn't totally coherent i was by
the time that we got to this part of the
movie
the slow spots had kind of made me not
pay as much attention yeah i think i was
kind of like i wasn't dozing off but i
was
going out facing well because i got to a
thing where and the use of i mean
you this is like a hallmark of a lot of
really low budget
and like i said i don't want to [ __ ] on
anybody that makes low budget films
because i know
it's hard and it's like that's your
dream and everything like that but i
think a lot of low-budget movies and
ouija shark had the same
thing that that it suffers
when you're trying to when you have like
a good concept but you don't have enough
budget or you don't have enough material
to fill up 90 minutes yeah
so i feel like there's a lot of just
like
hanging around yeah the movie you know
what i mean it's kind of all like that
it's like let's get some friends over
action let's just walk through the woods
for like
25 [ __ ] minutes of this movie so we
made it stronger
yeah like i said roger corman was like
really bad for there was other movies
too like if you've seen one
mystery science theater like there was
that one what the [ __ ] was it called
planet of the dinosaurs
i think literally 50 minutes of that
movie was them just like walking from
place to place
like in the desert it was oh my god
this one's not that bad though this one
yeah this that movie seemed like it was
like eight hours long
this one has about 20 minutes of it of
too much movie
yeah like i'm just like hey here's the
house hey let's have an argument over
something
or hey let's let's play pinball yeah for
a while
and what that does is it throws you out
of the [ __ ] tempo of the story
and it kind of undermines the humor of
it and the charm of the movie because
now you have to put up with the scene it
really doesn't have to be there
it's not essential to telling the story
yeah i mean i did and i didn't think you
needed like if you were going to do
the globetrotting exorcist uncle that
was going around
um you know capturing different evil
spirits if you were going to go
in that direction because there was the
one thing where he was talking about
like i said that dude that saw the grim
and you know he went into the lore about
like you know the
early like [ __ ] where they'd say like
you know they used to like the first
person that was buried in a new church
yard was supposed to be the guardian of
the church and they didn't want to like
put all the burden on that person's
ghost or whatever
so then they started doing it like to a
black dog and that is actually like
folklore i don't know if it ever
actually happened or not but that is
actually some folklore because we looked
it up
so like that kind of [ __ ] was it was
cool and interesting
and i feel like you could have made a
whole movie just out of that
yeah um and then
had less with the niece and nephew at
the cabin
right like and that like or you could
just come to them like
you know briefly like in between and
then at the end like oh [ __ ]
all the all the spirits got out of the
liquor bottle if the director and
producer or whatever
probably the director producer is
probably the same person that said you
know if
it's one of those kind of things if
you're if you're watching if you're
watching this review
really you really need to see
velocipaster that's a good example we
recommend that everything
that's a great example of a very little
book that's like a five dollar movie
done
right yeah and a lot of it has to do
with this with the edit the speed of
that movie
how that how that movie flows this movie
could
be re-edited um
you'd lose a lot of it you'd probably
end up being about 35 minutes long but
it would be a much
more fun film i do feel like indie
filmmakers
should maybe like don't worry so much
about making it
like 80 or 90 minutes if you don't have
i mean some movies do
obviously need to be that long or some
movies need to be three four hours long
or it needs to be a series or something
like that
but i think people would benefit from
knowing
like the story that you have to tell you
know how much can you cut out of that i
mean
if the movie just ends up being 45
minutes then so be it
like don't try to make it like longer
than it is and be like hey let's have
some shots of just like everybody
hanging around eating hot dogs at a bar
there may be
something in licensing or something
where
it has to be an hour and a half for them
to qualify for some kind of
tax break or some kind of a [ __ ]
royalty bonus or some [ __ ] like that
there may be something in there
well there's not as many well the thing
i think what i think it is
is i think there's not as many outlets
for short films
because i think most like even film
festivals even [ __ ] like that
i think the perception is that short
films are like how you start out with
[ __ ]
yeah and it's like you know you put that
on youtube for free
and then hopefully somebody's like hey
you're a genius you should make a movie
and then you make a full length one
because i feel like shorts they kind of
all get like a film festival will be
like oh okay well we're having a
saturday night where we show like a [ __ ]
ton of them
right so i feel like people just want
you know what i mean it's kind of like
when i write short stories
it's like it's really hard you can't
just put out a short story by itself you
have to have enough short stories for a
book
and whatever it has to be like in a you
know and what i would have done is i
would have made this a short
and then had the sequel to the short in
the same movie and called that a movie
because the movie just ends this movie
just ends
the ending was a little abrupt but in a
way i kind of liked the way they
ended up handing this okay it's like a
[ __ ] you ending
it's like we're all [ __ ] which that's
fine yeah that's fine
but they're wrong to the end yeah really
that should have been the end of an act
you didn't mean that [ __ ] like the end
of act three and then all of a sudden
you come in with like a couple more acts
to unfuck it you got [ __ ] now let's
unfuck it
yeah and then you would have had your
movie but i think there was budgetary
constraints
well yeah obviously yeah yeah that's the
thing it's kind of like i you know and
i'm not saying
that you know ending a movie on like
everything's [ __ ] to the end
um that can work yeah i'm just saying
that a lot of times like in horror
movies
it's better like for the protagonists to
be more
proactive i guess and to like fight
against because it seems like in
in this movie it seemed like they didn't
really ever know what was going on
yeah i mean those people like the
exorcist dude was the only dude that
knew what was going on
and that the two of them never got
together at any point did they like they
never met
i think the only reason that they that
the sister like found out about the
demon [ __ ] was because she opened
some package that the uncle had sent her
from like 1983 or something that had
been in the house the whole time and she
never got it
so then she was just like oh [ __ ] let's
tell everybody not to drink the liquor
out of the bottles except of course they
already had
so everyone was like already in trouble
but they didn't really so they didn't
like have the information
to do anything about
all the [ __ ] that was happening i mean
even if they had failed which you
probably would if like all the [ __ ]
evil spirits got out and like what the
[ __ ] would you do about that
nothing you couldn't do anything about
that
although even though this was a
very imperfect movie
i still appreciated that
that it how it had a lot of good
qualities to it yeah
it's like it was a ch it was kind of
charming like it was something really
charming about it
they whoever made the movie cared about
the movie yeah
all right um and they they knew what
kind of movie it was
you know it had the certain aspects and
certain
certain moments of it that i liked it
had a good score it had it had
it had some [ __ ] that made you made you
laugh you know what i mean like
they go into the old abandoned house and
it's supposed to be oh this abandoned
house and they got the [ __ ] damn
cobwebs that are stretched from the
halloween
from the halloween store
i was just well i saw that and i was
like oh i got the accomplishment
[ __ ] cotton stretched out
that made me laugh yeah the movie really
wasn't taking itself seriously
right well you can't take care of it
there was too much filler in it yeah it
needed to be shortened and re-edited by
about 20. well like i said i mean the
concept it's a good concept
like i really liked the concept of like
all these different kinds of evil
spirits
that the exorcist knows about and he's
just like
he's so jaded like from going all around
the world and like
you know finding all these evil spirits
and that that was cool it's like they
should have done more with that
also did they ever do anything with you
know how
he was like sick i'm assuming because he
kept
[ __ ] with the evil spirit so that was
like making him sick i guess that was
the implication
did they ever do anything with that or
did he just i don't remember because he
was just like coughing all the time and
then like they didn't really like
follow up on that the problem is that
because there's
there's filler in the movie the tempo of
the movie
is uneven so you start your mind starts
wandering
yeah and then it's hard for you to get
back into it and hard for you to
remember what has already happened
because a bunch of stuff was said that
was not pertinent to the story
not really and then stuff that that
should have been pertinent like what
happened
a couple times yeah like you know like
the exorcist like being really sick like
they
had one scene where he was talking to
some other guy who they didn't really
explain who it was
and talking about you need a vacation
like you're gonna die from all this
or whatever and then like when he was
out on some
jobs or whatever like he'd be like
hacking and coughing or he fainted or
whatever but they didn't really like
follow up on that like did he die or did
he like what happened
there couldn't have been a a a real
script
for this or a tight script it was kind
of like they were
doing the italian method of making it up
as they were going
let's just while we're here we'll just
film all this kind of [ __ ] and then i'll
just cobble it too okay
i'll god blend together it'll make sense
i promise later yeah
i think that's what's going on but yeah
it's like
this was a totally fine you know i don't
know if i'd like recommend it if
because there's like a lot of other ones
you could be watching but it doesn't
cost anything to watch it
the moment it's free on tubey yeah um so
if it sounds like fun like i said it's
it gets kind of long in the middle and
the
you know the overdubbing was a little um
annoying it could give you a chuckle i
guess it did
yeah i mean the the best part for me
was the part with and i don't even know
like i said i don't know what the [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] the yeti was
doing in this i don't know what the [ __ ]
and then like the one little demon or
whatever monster at the end like the
little puppet
that like that hit the little baby
monster that like hid inside the teddy
bear
yeah that was probably my favorite part
of it because like i don't know i just
promise i like that little monster
problem is by the time you get there you
become kind of indifferent to the movie
that's what happened that's what
happened to me i was kind of like okay
i went through you know this this you
know 15 20 minutes of kind of filler
all right now the movie's back and
what's going on what happened
and then even and i'm like good at
following stuff and even i was just kind
of like
following it i was like i kind of you
know what yeah you know what you know
what that in terms of being able to
follow it you know what it reminds me of
transfers never transfers i couldn't
follow you you could hard to follow
transfers like what the [ __ ] is going on
in this and it's not because i'm dumb
it's because it didn't make any sense
it had it had like transfers had a
beginning and an
end but the middle you don't know what
the [ __ ] happened
they're like well we kind of hoped we
wrote the beginning a really good
beginning and a really good end and then
just
in the middle what was that [ __ ] was
that a miracle occurs it was like we
don't know we don't know what happened
watch the scenes in a bunch of dialogue
and you didn't know what any of that
[ __ ] meant
it's just all a bunch it's all in there
custard in the middle we're trying to
like
push it together into something coherent
and it didn't quite work out yeah
transfers was totally incredible
and they made like this did actually
kind of remind me of that
you know i'm talking about yeah that's
that's it speaking of making nine of
something
another movie that is on to be right now
is camp blood part eight yo
now i've never seen any of the camp
blood movies however i know of them
because good old johnny [ __ ] case over
at shitcase cinema
on youtube has done at least one of them
maybe several
and so when i was scrolling through the
horror movies on to be last night i was
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're on the eighth camp blood movie
this is
that's another like super super cheap
like slasher movie what's that oh your
phone ran
is my phone ringing yeah
i mean a couple people call me but not
very often
so i just don't even answer it because i
don't have time for that [ __ ]
but yeah so but yeah can't blood eight
we'll have to watch that too
well like i said well i don't know i
don't know if i could sit through that
i'm so
kind of i i'm kind of tempted by viking
versus krampus though
it might be all right i mean that's
looked kind of fun check it out
we might watch that one tonight it
probably
sucks yeah but if you're gonna make
something called vikings versus krampus
you better have like a little bit of a
budget yeah for that [ __ ] like for
costumes and everything come on probably
just a dude in the [ __ ] santa claus
outfits like the grinch or something
painted it [ __ ] green green
dude
[ __ ] krampus i'm krampus with some
horns on it
put some horns on yeah that's probably
all that would be really funny if you
had somebody with like a santa claus but
then with horns
yeah he's santa krampus yeah yeah
that's kind of like that christmas
horror story movie where it was like
santa vs krampus
yeah with and all the zombie elves that
was a super fun movie
yeah but this one uh can i recommend it
no
it can not kinda not really
yeah i'm not super enthused about it i
liked the i liked the concept
and like some of the [ __ ] was funny like
i liked the little monster
that was disguised like a teddy bear
like i liked that yeah the special
effects part was
and one thing i i feel like they wrote
this entire movie
because hey we can go to this town it
was i can't remember the name of the
town but it was in upstate new york
somewhere
and they're like hey we can record the
fireworks for fourth of july and the
fourth of july parade
because they put a lot of that in there
so there are actually like a big
firework display and all this kind of
other things because they have to pay
for because they didn't have to pay for
it you just went down there and filmed
it they're like woohoo
there's like a quarter of our baby yeah
look at that yeah
it was just kind of like that but um i
was like well you know
points for [ __ ] they're thinking it
through that's what i mean
yeah and when and i'm just saying i
don't you know i don't make films
but if i did i would always i would
advise like getting your location
and your [ __ ] like your costumes and
[ __ ] together first and see what you
have
and like let's write a story around that
yeah
that's just like [ __ ] one of my
favorite flicks man john carpenter
escape from new york the whole reason
why that movie happened is because they
had a [ __ ] burned out part of what
was it chicago
no it was uh nah saint louis
lewis or something it was somewhere like
some big fire that you wouldn't think of
some big fire happened and burns down a
[ __ ] large portion of the city and
they said that's where we're going to
film our movie
because you could just run around that
part of town all day long it just looked
like a [ __ ] post-apocalyptic because
it was
i mean look what they did with [ __ ]
session nine they're like hey we have a
big huge
abandoned mental hospital let's like
write some [ __ ] around that because it's
creepy as [ __ ] and that was an awesome
movie but i just feel like
don't write the story first and have
like all this like dragons and
spaceships and all this other kind of
[ __ ] in it and then you try to make it
for like it's like oh
we have 15 dollars so we're gonna have
to make some [ __ ] out of card
remember when that mouse is not gonna
work out when mount st helen's blue it
[ __ ]
put all that [ __ ] volcanic ash
everywhere remember back as a 1980
1980 yeah they should have [ __ ]
written a movie around that whole
[ __ ] thing
yeah see if somebody was thinking ahead
an asteroid impact or a [ __ ] nuclear
war or something that
just made your movie right there and all
that ash it's like free set
design yeah that's what you gotta do
always thinking ahead always thinking
ahead yeah uh
uh mega badger also said along with you
guys i really recommend
the pool great film that really was very
good i liked that very much
and like i said that probably wasn't
super high budget either no you know
but because it was all pretty much like
in one location yeah they needed money
for the cgi of like crocodile and stuff
i'm watching a video that came out today
[ __ ] news uh one of these damn
big hollywood studios just basically has
lost
900 million dollars because of this
[ __ ] pandemic
yeah and all these [ __ ] lockdowns and
they're just doing an
analysis of the [ __ ] hollywood film
industry
after the closure of [ __ ] amc and how
much money
emc theaters will not survive most
likely [ __ ] see
the major theater chains won't survive i
have heard though that
drive-ins are making that might come
back right because you can sit in your
own car but that will only be rural
because the the property taxes would
only be
yeah you need a lot of room somewhere
else for that um
the theaters that are shut down or are
right now
because of the [ __ ] lockdowns are
just [ __ ]
hemorrhaging money totally on they won't
be able to recover
uh the property taxes alone so
and then they're trying and then the
theaters are trying to use their muscle
against the studios
so to to to keep them from releasing on
video on demand
um which the studios are sort of say
[ __ ] you we're gonna release
the studios are so far behind they won't
be able to release any new movies for a
year now
so a lot of people didn't think of that
[ __ ] uh disney's totally [ __ ]
uh because star wars [ __ ] up um
there it's just the [ __ ] hollywood
apocalypse so a lot of the [ __ ] you're
hearing
coming out of [ __ ] hollywood and
hollywood celebrities
it's desperation because they're just
[ __ ] in having their own
[ __ ] apocalypse and it's been
demonstrated that a hollywood
a-listers make piss-poor
[ __ ] youtubers they're getting on
there trying to make youtube channels so
they [ __ ] fall into
tripping over their own decks online and
they just they just they
because of the [ __ ] environment that
a-listers come from
and the fact that they just they're not
really free to say anything
or to speak their mind they can't act
like regular people
on on a youtube show and think on their
feet and that's just
they have to be totally scripted and
they need a whole [ __ ] council of
[ __ ] people behind them to
advise them what was the best thing to
say you know
it's just that era is gone
the only uh there will be theaters but
they're gonna be very niche
uh and it'll only be in big cities and
they'll probably be expensive and
they'll probably have restaurants and
[ __ ]
bars in them and um well every theater
needs a bar
yeah and they'll be very uh expensive
they won't be for regular people
and then everybody else will be
streaming now there's having a big
[ __ ] battle behind all the [ __ ]
platforms now
hbo wants a streaming platform
platformer too many [ __ ] streaming
platforms
uh disney [ __ ] plus is failing just
all these little [ __ ] platforms are
not gonna [ __ ] make it
these are all control freaks and big
corporations trying to make money off
these [ __ ] movies
and this data i don't want any more
[ __ ] streaming services and most
everybody else doesn't want them you end
up spending [ __ ] 250 bucks a month
150 bucks a month on all these [ __ ]
streaming i mean generally
we have netflix we have shutter those
are not good enough
and yeah and and 2b is free um
and then if there's movies that aren't
on any of those
then we just rent them one at a time for
like three or four dollars yes
the future is gonna be a la carte
a la carte [ __ ] off of amazon or off
your [ __ ] xbox
which is funny because that's what even
back in the days of [ __ ] old days of
cable tv
right everybody wanted that like it's
like can we just have these five or ten
channels that i watch instead of you
giving me this whole [ __ ] package
with 100 channels with [ __ ] 80
channels i'm never going to watch
um so i think it's better now that i
mean it's very fragmented but it's
better because you can just like pick
and choose what you want and not like
spend zillions of dollars yeah and you
see the fat cats don't
don't want that because that's not
they can't force feed you to [ __ ] buy
[ __ ] now you know
you can't can't run a scams anymore
internet the internet is democratizing
everything and everything's becoming
scam proof
and most dudes in that in in the
entertainment industry
got rich off scam and those days those
days are over
the future is going to be a la carte
purchasing
that's how you do it you know what i
mean but i mean that's why and honestly
that's why i kind of like even if we see
a movie like
distiller that wasn't like fantastic i
would rather
you know um throw a couple bucks toward
the person that made that
yeah at least at least the filmmakers
getting the [ __ ] money
yeah let him get his money he made it
yeah these middlemen man they they just
they're not gonna survive yeah and
that's why they're [ __ ] losing their
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but these middlemen you gotta [ __ ]
look at the situation these dudes are
all old men they're all in their 70s and
80s some of them are in their [ __ ]
90s
they've had their they've had a good run
sit the [ __ ] down and shut the [ __ ] up
that your your time's over man let some
youngsters make some movies
you're you are technological you're
technologically obsolete you're
culturally obsolete
you're you're 70 something years old
[ __ ] retire
i mean you've got billions of dollars
sit the [ __ ] back with your [ __ ] 30
year old trophy wife
and [ __ ] enjoy the rest of the time
that [ __ ] you have
get the [ __ ] out of here man [ __ ] was
sick of your ass
i just want to put on my xbox and watch
the movie that i want to watch
yeah i don't want to [ __ ] buy all
this other [ __ ] i don't want to see
commercials and [ __ ] i mean like i said
i don't mind like netflix is good to
have because they have like a bunch of
[ __ ] that i like
um shutters good and you know i really
like shutter and it's cheap
and like i said other than that in 2b
and just renting
like a one-off every now and then if
it's if we find one that's not a
and any of the other platforms i mean we
have like
pretty much more than enough [ __ ] that
we can watch just
through those so i don't really feel the
need to get any yeah
i can't believe tom has an xbox inferior
i got a xbox one that's what the [ __ ]
i did i don't give a [ __ ] about all this
inferior console man all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay i play old video games on
it
i go down there and [ __ ] gets i'm
[ __ ] buying [ __ ] video games from
the [ __ ]
early 2000s and playing them well you
got all those 80s i got 80s games you
know i mean
i'll play [ __ ] 8-bit in 16-bit games
all right do you have burger time on
that [ __ ] no
i have the whole williams arcade and
[ __ ] like that
and uh you know i just i like what i
like you know what i mean [ __ ]
a lot of the new games are as soulless
as these new movies
so you know i i do me dude
i do i don't give a [ __ ] about your
console you do like fallout and stuff
i like fallout while i fall out for you
and you know
i don't i don't play a lot of video
games but even i'm entertained by
um all right so we've been going on for
like 45 minutes
i'm just here scratching my ear
all right so we'll probably be back
again tomorrow maybe we'll review
vikings versus krampus or maybe we'll
find something else who knows it's going
to be a surprise
it's going to be a surprise to us so
it'll be a surprise to you as well
so as usual thanks everybody for
dropping by
and we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow bye